on May 12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP
ubu manifested in Kangas Greenland like
something out of the most nightmarish
Kaiju movie never made soon after there
was no more death but the world was
filled with such chaos and despair that
Humanity longed for that Eternal release
from its enormous stomping feet to its
cloa to its face featureless save for a
gaping grinning devouring mouth The
Entity was pure malice with all the time
in the world ubu decimated the planet
breaking the spirit of mankind and
raising every city to the ground in the
earlier days of ubu's invasion when
there was still dry land and people
still wanted to talk to each other
rather than joining floating islands of
Eternal chemically induced Slumber they
would commiserate about the shared
misery of the state of things oh U my
daughter hasn't spoken to me ever since
that monster shove my whole body down
her throat someone would say another
would pipe up trying to one up the first
man in sort of a trauma Olympics didn't
you see me in the news ubu carried me
around for a week snacking on me every
now and then like I was his own personal
Turkey Leg it was hell but honestly part
of me felt a little bummed out when he
threw me away yet another person would
chime in like veteran swapping War
Stories over a drink at the bar ubu made
me eat a pair of my pants whole thing
zipper and all then he decided he
thought that was funny made me eat pair
after pair after pair of them rinse and
repeat by the time he got bored i' had
eaten probably around 20 paars and sort
of got a taste for them after that
everyone on the planet had good reason
to despise SCP U but no one held more
hate in his heart for the pale Wicked
creature than Dr Lawrence mikal before
the world was turned upside down
sometimes literally Dr moud was a member
of the mysterious 05 council at the SCP
Foundation to be specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song Centuries
after that awful experience as Dr moud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr mcod abandoned the
scps Nay Smith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn crate
an abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
un hunched but before he could row any
closer something collided with the
lifebo From Below snapping it in half Dr
macau's stomach dropped at the sight of
pale flesh but it was soon replaced with
relief when he saw that the thing that
had broken his lifebo was not in fact
ubu it was an injured narwhal behaving
erratically due to its wounds the
culprit was almost certainly ubu it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain pain and
fear in his own words Dr moud had put it
at least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the lifebo
broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the ganam list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crake if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud embarked
on an initial exploration of The Craft
all the staff were gone as he had
expected thankfully he still had his 05
ID card and it's still still worked like
a charm unlocking all of the automated
security systems on board a lot of what
he found was in Ruins but some things
had survived he found 10 hominid
replicators from SCP 2000 in perfect
working order there was a cage
containing the remains of SCP 2845 the
deer though ubu had done significant
damage to it SCP 319 a curious device
was there contained in a space locked
vacuum chamber this one was notable for
its potential ability to destroy the
universe he found a couple of safe class
anomalies such as SCP yez crowd control
for the Practical Optimist and SCP FNA
the portable warehouse the latter of the
two was a portable door frame to a
pocket Dimension he also stumbled upon
SCP 001 Last Ride of the day an old
Prometheus Labs prototype of a time
machine and possibly most importantly he
found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr macow he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed not 9
days after he first inspected the corn
CR mik began to formulate a plan he
loaded all the hominid receptors into
SCP FNA using a thankfully still working
forklift next he was able to unseal the
sealed portion of SCP 001 Last Ride of
the day and get his hands on the details
of the anomaly it read SCP 001 is
capable of temporally relocating to its
relative position 15,000 years prior to
activation this temporal displacement is
Divergent Paradox Irrelevant in other
words a separate timeline is created as
a landing point for example if an
occupant from timeline X were to murder
their parents in utero in Timeline y the
Y iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 001 deploys a 5 m
High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy syn essentially
coloo waves could only be produced as a
byproduct of the universe suddenly being
exterminated and ZK class reality
failures produced the most Colo waves in
one of these scenarios SC SCP 001 would
be able to use these waves to go back in
time 15,000 years effectively resetting
reality to a point far before the
catastrophe happened this information
allowed him to put his plan together to
resurrect project Beluga step one plant
explosive charges around scp3 19 step
two hide anything potentially useful
against SCP ubu inside of SCP FNA step
three get into the cockpit with SCP FNA
and toe step four raise the Colo sink
and step five blow the whole thing up 3
days later it was time to put the plan
into motion Dr moud placed the charges
around SCP 319s vacuum chamber there was
enough in place to implode the walls of
the vacuum chamber he closed the
bulkhead and began to deploying the Colo
syn 10% 25% 30% suddenly he could hear a
loud crashing sound the ship began to
tilt oh no he could hear the distant
sound of menacing Giggles the sync
reached 45 57 but as ubu grew closer he
quickly overrode the system to lower the
sink 45% 30% 25% 10% ubu grew closer and
closer and as it approached it began to
whistle the tune it once used when it
bathed moud and his wife in the sewer
ubu began to pound against the blast
door becoming increasingly frustrated as
it struggled to break through suddenly
another voice cut through the air an
unexpected one SCP 076 Abel called out
to maoud encouraging him to carry on
while Abel held the Beast back as Abel
and yubu engaged in an epic battle maow
suddenly remembered something there was
an Express deployment module for the col
Co syn with no time to waste he
activated it all at once once he hit the
Detonator and then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in black paint in spite of this the
object was given the designation as CP
848 a narrow winding tunnel through the
mound of Earth and snow was discovered
leading from the door to the outside
world the tunnel had significant wear
clearly having been used as a foot path
by someone but who well on April 12th
1993 the foundation got their answer SCP
848 bulk had opened and a man stepped
out snapping his fingers and promptly
sealing the door behind him he was
designated po
8048 he was a 32-year-old man of French
Canadian descent answering to the name
of Dr Lawrence moud he made a series of
claims that the foundation found dubious
but noted it in the official file for
SCP 848 just the same these included but
were not limited to SCP 848 is a time
machine he held the office of 05-11 in
the year 3030 from an alternate timeline
said timeline experienced a modified
Omega K class endof death scenario that
coincided with the invasion of a Tiamat
class anomaly known as SCP ubu SCP ubu
was an extremely dangerous and sadistic
entity who was capable of among other
things neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682
his timelines version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible war with SCP ubu that
lasted 441 years Paul 848 deliberately
sabotaged SCP 319 to act act as a power
source for SCP 88848 thus arriving in
Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a Central Computer within SCP
848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal homed replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SC P yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document 8048
dzeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
moud mentioned over4 specific terms and
data points known only to members of the
05 Council the foundation was forced to
take him at least a little bit seriously
a motion was filed requesting that poll
848 be allowed to assist the foundation
with the termination of SCP ubu as per
document 848 Zeta 054 voted yay 057
abstained and the rest of the council
voted nay the motion failed to pass a
follow-up motion was filed in response
requesting that poll 848 be allowed to
assist the foundation with their own
strategy to respond to SCP ubu 05-10 5-4
057 and 05-10 abstain from voting the
rest voted nay the motion failed to pass
on April 14th 1995 Dr Isaiah Henderson
and pole 848 sat down for an interview
when asked to State his name Dr maau
also recited a mimetic passphrase that
when spoken by anyone other than 05-11
of past or present would cause them to
burst into flames the two men were at
odds from the beginning Dr maau
expressed dismay and frustration that
his proposal was rejected meanwhile Dr
Henderson countered with the insistence
that macau's proposed plan was rejected
for posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr mow
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 054 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr
Macau returned to the bulkhead climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him he
had hoped to have the foundation behind
him he had hoped they would be allies in
the fight against the greatest evil
mankind ever encountered but they
disappointed him he had waited thousands
of years only for the organization he
devoted his life to to try and kill him
well he wasn't going to go down without
a fight this was bigger than the
foundation
bigger than anyone and no living person
was as equipped to handle ubu as he was
so he resumed project Beluga as a oneman
operation he issued a mission statement
which read as follows on May 12th 2588
The Entity known as SCP ubu invaded and
pillaged human civilization for no other
motivation than cruelty and selfish
gratification shortly thereafter project
Beluga was founded as a joint effort
between deblo cult Coalition and the SCP
Foundation for the purposes of ubu's
Destruction ubu is not merely a threat
to human safety he's an affront to every
positive and loving Concept in the human
consciousness rather than our lives he
seeks to destroy our quality of life to
sa his own sick desires think about it
the taste of ice cream playing with your
dog the way you felt after your first
kiss that is yuu's sworn Enemy No fate
is too cool for him no hatred is strong
enough when project Beluga Charter was
signed 592 go officers and Foundation
staff were present at the ceremony our
troops numbered in the hundreds of
thousands I Dr Lin moud am the only
surviving member and always will be what
I lack in numbers is compensated
thousandfold by my weapons my mind my
replicated bodies and the ons of
experience the following record serves
one purpose alone that once justice has
been brought to ubu humans in The
Shining golden ubu free future will
understand that one person can
accomplish through the power of hard
science and R motion entwined in a
perfect and indestructible braid and
while we are at it you are very welcome
over the next several hundred years mow
worked to secure ownership of conaso
Greenland through a project Beluga
civilian front he evacuated the civilian
population from the area then spent a
century constructing a super weapon with
100 high yield nuclear weapons Heat
amplif a runes a targeting Beacon for
SCP dag and five antimatter Gathering
pods from SCP H&M in place he was
finally ready for ubu to manifest again
now check out the 05 Council Must Die
SCP 001 the way it ends or aoro cycle
and insane SCP 001 fight gate Guardian
versus scarlet King